hey guys Ryan's here Sally get off your
phone get off your phone get the [ __ ]
off your phone phone is off we're gonna
check out the trailer today the TV spot
for Jurassic world the park is open come
on over the parks open Brynner's
dinosaurs this comes out on Jerry's
birthday no we discussed this earlier if
dinosaurs existed today we would go
extinct due to them [ __ ] killing us
all the time you don't need to be in a
movie to do that you could probably go
to a place where they have the
animatronic okay let's watch this Sally
the Park Service
she's killing for sport
evacuate the island
I would love to go a theme park like
that yeah they make it look very
appealing I am so excited to watch this
movie I genuinely am it looks like it's
captured really well there's just one
thing I cannot get over
where did they possibly think a hybrid
dinosaur would be any kind of good idea
to create the second I heard that in the
first trailer I was like no it's already
kind of hard to predict dinosaurs today
there's no point in also it's already
kinda hard to like have hybrid animals
like I would have been around since
we've been around why all of a sudden
would you take this thing that you don't
even know what it's capable of yeah
makes it like what the hell like I
didn't exactly I can understand [ __ ]
neighbors I can understand that if they
want to link generate more money to the
theme park but first of all it's a
freaking dinosaur theme park like you
would probably have all the money in the
world who wouldn't want to see that how
do they keep the pterodactyls there
though they could just fly like anyway
sure they have them in some kind of cage
that's so cruel yeah we bring
prehistoric creatures back to life so
they could become an amusement park the
trash okay there's a couple of things
I'm having a hard time getting over how
they were able to get this park open
after the eat countless times this is
proven to not be good for someone
the hybrid dinosaur the fact that Chris
Pratt can train Raptors and might
communicate with them I guess if you get
a little bored for that
I thought Raptors are like the most
freakin crazy though like I think they
were the smartest there are the smartest
like why wouldn't he want to get close
to a human well because you know he
trains them and that way they become his
friend but I did like about this trailer
though was when they said the hybrid
dinosaur killed its sibling because if
that's the hybrid dinosaurs own sibling
that shows at times into other Jurassic
Park films you see these dinosaurs will
still care about like their time
but if this dinosaur is like no [ __ ] it
I'm just gonna kill
whatever comes my way that is pretty
terrible it's a hybrid and it's sibling
isn't then of course they want to kill
it because like them yeah that's still
at least reconsider if you're thinking
about doing it yeah if you answer new to
the channel you can subscribe to the REO
rejects sally has a sad sadness tell you
has a sandal has a channel you can check
that out too you follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter we need more followers
we need more followers
I'm sick of only looking at a hundred
likes whenever I post a photo I want
more likes I want to be like ariana
grande and have like millions of
Instagram followers because I know I
want to be like Mark Ruffalo and get a
lot of Instagram followers Tony Fraser
hey real rejects I love your videos
especially your reaction uploads I make
any sci-fi comedy game and the main
characters persona is based around Ryan
cool it would be amazing if you would
give me a shout-out because you guys are
inspirational that is so cool I based
around me can i voice it can i boys
shitty game that would be so cool it
like a voyeur game man put that on IMDB
the end bus that says for impotent men
down sized penises downsizing I could
see why you want to base a character off
of me I'm witty pure wit no dick jokes
she has a friend who likes to make Nick
Jonas sometimes these are strict jokes
and you can pick jokes but don't let you
these are sick jokes Oh witty wit had a
big tits and up [ __ ]